- I'm only allowed to
sing songs where I yell.
'Cause I like, I don't sing,
'cause if I sing I could
sing, I would be a stripper.
(Kelly laughing heartily)
- Did you say "If I could
sing, I'd be a stripper."
- God could not trust
me with a singing voice.
He knows, like he knows who he can trust.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- 'Cause I would be
that person, like "how you doin'?"
Yeah. Yeah. Like I just
chocolate testimony would
be my stripper name.
- Chocolate testimony
- I have the whole thing planned out
but that's why God's like,
- You have got to make that show.
(laughter)
- It keeps me humble.
Like I can't, I can't have
six-pack abs because again
I would wear a pasties
to church and I just don't
think that's appropriate.
- Oh my, I think God would frown.
- I think, I think he'd be like, daughter,
what are we doing?
So he keeps me humble
with like a humble pouch.
And like, ah
(tongue click)
- I always say that about some hot.
Like I was like, what I see.
So heck I'm like
God didn't allow me to look
that good for a reason.
I would be just walking around naked.
She's so beautiful.
- You'll have to know your limitations.
And he hadn't used them
before, you know, like, yeah
you gotta, you gotta go girl, please.
- You are so funny